audrey candidate sur la 2e
circonscription des deux-sèvres
cette circonscription c est une terre
agricole
culture d'élevage de maraîchage c'est
aussi une carte touristique avec un
patrimoine historique authentique et un
environnement naturel exceptionnel du
marais poitevin à la cathine poitevine
du haut val de sèvre hauts plateaux
belloir je connais ce territoire j'y vis
depuis 18 ans
je connais les enjeux et les
problématiques liées à la peau mate
j'ai été conseillère municipale puis
adjointe et conseillère communautaire
et l'an dernier j'ai rejoint la liste de
la droite et du centre pour les
élections régionales avec nicolas
c'est donc tout naturellement que je me
présente aux élections législatives sous
les mêmes couleurs sous les mêmes
valeurs de la droite et du centre car
c'est le parti et protège ses citoyens
et qui défend l'art iranien
[Musique]